hi in this class we're going to work on
the movement of our free leg because I
believe that the way you move your
freedom
when you dance defines your style the
style of your dancing if you think about
it when you look at a couple dancing in
a show or socially in a milonga usually
if you look at their legs your eyes
get attracted to the free leg because
the standing leg is quite limited in the
things you can do it can basically stand
to keep your balance it can bend or
stretch in order to push or to change of
height or it can pivot to change the
direction of your dancing but that's it
that's it the free leg can do lots of
things can go from one point to another
to take the next step in between going
from one point to another you can add or
and there is a low or high and even if
you don't at all the way you look from
one step to the next for example
starting with the knee
I mean the food or starting with the
food or going slowly or going with more
accent this really establishes the style
and the character of your dancing so we
are going to work on that on basic
positions for the freedom from inside
back and how to go to them and we're
going to pay special attention to the
position of the foot when you go to each
position of the leg to its direction so
we will start with a warm-up then we
will practice these positions static one
by one then we will combine the
positions so that we learn to move our
legs
between them and then to challenge
ourselves we're going to combine the
positions of the freely with people's of
the standing leg that would be on there
so I hope you enjoyed our let's go to
the workout let's start with a warm-up
is that we the same warm-up as the other
two classes so we start with feet
together and we will shoulder rotations
we do it eight times one two three four
five six seven eight okay now we do
circles with the arms
oh yeah remember keep the shoulders down
and the elbows straight okay and we do
eight times one two three four
five six seven and eight
okay now we stretch this on the dorsal
side stretches remember we go with one
arm up and then we slide the hand down
okay we touch the knee and then we use
the hand that is up to return to the
vertical position and with all four
times to each side so one to touch the
knee up three down three
that's the knee down last one for touch
me now now we open the legs with
underneath we keep the hip and the head
looking forward and with rotations of
the torso make a circle with arms and we
do sixteen times each side one two three
four five six seven eight more one two
three four five
and six seven and eight
now with today's nummies and we bend
down we put the head the hands behind
the head and then we Bend on the hips
until here okay seven bounce bounce
bounce bounce bounce bounce okay
we keep the legs open and now we do
circles with the hip we grab our hips we
go back we keep the knees straight and
the heels on the ground and then we went
to the side and then forward and then
side and then back and we don't move the
head and keep it on
the center okay we do eight tweaks
direction so we start back and then we
start one two three four five six seven
and eight and change direction one two
[Music]
three four five six eight okay now the
last one we lose our feet legs together
and we do relaxing the knees bounce
three times one two three and then
stress the knees go up on the toes and
hold it for three seconds okay
and we'll wait eight times so one bounce
bounce bounce
stretch up hold and down to bounce
bounce bounce trench up hold and down
three bounce bounce bounce
stretch up hold and down four bounce
bounce bounce stretch hold and down five
bounce bounce bounce
stretch up hold on down six bounce
bounce bounce
stretch up hold and down seven bounce
stretch up hold and down and last one
they bounce bounce bounce
stretch up hold and down okay we're
ready with a woman okay now we will do a
hibernation exercise
which we will roll our free foot when
this first we will put our free leg in
the front position then in the side
position that in the back position we
will do it with both legs and in each
position we are going to roll our feet
16-time first in one direction and then
in the other direction so start with
feet together if you want
grab your hips this will help with
balance and then put your weight on the
left leg extend the right leg front
without touching the floor point the
foot and then roll the foot 16 times to
the other side 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 8 more 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 now change direction 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 8 more 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 and 8 now
change weight and let's do it with the
other leg with a lift first to the
outside 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 8 more 1 2 3 4 5
six seven eight on a plain side one two
three four five six seven and eight more
one two three four five six seven and
eight now changing the weight again and
now extend the right leg to the side
we'll do the same to the side first we
roll the foot 16 times to the outside 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 8 more 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
none to the inside 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 8
more 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 & 8
now to change weight and we do the same
with the left foot first we roll it to
the outside 16 times 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 8
more 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 and now to the inside
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 and 8 more 1 2
three four five six seven and eight now
change weight and now extend the right
leg to the back and we rotate we roll
the three foot 16 times to the outside
one two three four and five six seven
eight
eight more one two three four five six
seven eight now to inside 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 8 1 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 and 8
now change weight and extend the left
leg to the body rotate it 16 times to
the outside 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 8 more 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8
and now rotated to inside 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 8 more 1 2 3 4 5
six seven and eight
okay we are done with the preparation
exercises let's go to a next book okay
so now we are going to work on the
movement of our free leg when we step
forward or side or back and we are going
to pay special attention to the position
of our foot in each one of these
positions so when you go forward like
this what you do with the foot is that
you turn the food so that the outside of
the foot is touching the floor and the
inside is up yeah this is called knife
in bamboo Coutinho
yeah is the name of the position of the
food the small toe is touching the floor
and the big toe result when you return
to zero position that is is the opposite
you rotate the food so that the inside
of the foot is touching the floor and
the outside is up this position I don't
think it has a name I call it pretty
because it looks pretty
now the the knees inside towards the
other meaning the toe is a it's like it
feels pretty anyway I call it that way
when you go to the side you don't have
to change the food you keep the pretty
position with the inside down and the
outside up you only need to extend up in
the foot so that the toes stay on the
floor and then when you go back like
this what you do is that you extend the
food so that the toes are pointing down
to the floor this position I call it
toes because it's about the toes going
down be careful that your heel doesn't
go outside
this looks horrible your heel has to
stay inside it's very similar to the
pretty position only you extend the foot
so that it's vertical and the toes are
pointing down okay so what we are going
to do is first we will start with feet
together and embraced and embrace we
will start from zero position pretty
position for the foot to the front ninth
and then return to zero we will do it
sixteen times with one day and then when
you learn it then we change the weight
we will go from zero to side and then
back to zero
okay side and zero 16 times and then we
will repeat with the left leg 16 times
and then we will go back like this we
will go from the preety position in zero
position to the total position back in
the back position and then we'll return
to zero sixteen times with right leg 16
times from the left leg okay this would
be the sequence now usually I will do
this with music but we are going to use
the metronome the material I said it
like in the last class - its / by one
[Music]
and the tempos 58 BDM okay so we will
extend return to zero extend return to
zero now one tip about how to use the
middle way to the movement I recommend
that you keep your free leg q charities
always in movement always in movement
so don't move the leg fast and then
visit
and wait there this is wrong bum bum ya
this is wrong you have to adjust the
speed of your leg so that your leg is
always moving ladies yeah so don't do it
too fast do it slowly so that you can
always be moving the leg that's how you
work the movement the best so let's
start legs together bend the knees a
little bit relax
tango place put your weight on the left
and we're going to work on the run from
3t do not 16-1
[Music]
now okay five six seven eight change
okay now we will do it to the back we
were from pretty position in zero
position we extend the leg to the back
and we extend the foot so I will go to
the toes position big turn
remember heel inside okay baby it's go
to the next look okay in this book we're
going to combine the
the free food that we practice
separately in the previous book and we
will do two sequences of combinations
the first one is going to be like this
we start in zero position weight on the
left foot
and then with the right we're going to
start in zero position with a foot in
the pretty position remember inside of
the foot down outside up then from here
we will go front and we will put the
foot in the knife position outside down
inside then we'll return again to zero
foot in pretty position from here we'll
go to the society foot in pretty
position but extended so that the toes
reach to the floor and then again in
zero position foot in pretty position
and then from here to the back foot in
total position remember don't let your
heel go outside keep it inside
yeah extend the foot in the top position
and then from here to the zero position
again putting pretty position and then
to the side again extended pretty and
then zero in pretty position so four
movements knife pretty sight pretty zero
pretty back toes zero pretty side pretty
zero greedy and that's it
ok I'm gonna repeat this whole sequence
eight times then we'll change the way
I'm going to do it again with the left
leg okay now we will use the metronome
again
- it's per bar 50 80 bpm and remember
that when you use the metronome
try not to move your leg too fast so
that you have to wait at the end of each
position then we ladies adjust your
speed so that your
is always always because then you okay
[Music]
good the second combination is the
combination that you will do if you
would be walking forward and back so we
will leave out the side step and we will
use only the front and the back
positions so again we start in zero
position with a three foot in pretty
position then we go front and we use the
ninth position will return to zero
position foot in pretty position and
then we go back and the foot is in top
position and then again zero position so
it looks like this one two okay and then
we will change the weight and we will do
it with the left leg okay remember here
is extremely important that you don't do
breaks in each position the movement
should is fluid from 0 to 1 to 0 to back
to zero to zero to back to zero and in
each position you need to change
- yeah okay change weight left one
[Music]
okay we're done with this let's go to
the next room
okay we're going to combine the two
sequences that we did in the previous
book with people's do you remember this
exercise within the very first class for
periods where we were on one leg and
then we were doing 90 degrees spirits to
each side leg is 90 degrees 90 degrees
90 degrees 90 degrees yeah first the
torso then the hill yeah and then we the
same thing we were doing it to the other
side 90 degrees 90 degrees 90 degrees
degrees and then we do
with other day - one direction to the
other direction 90 so there yes to mix
this with the sequences that we have
been doing before so the way we are
going to mix it is language we start in
zero position and then we do the first
movement which is putting breathe
position then from a knife and then when
you collect to go back to zero position
you start turning the torso so that by
the time you reach the zero position you
do our pivot from here you are going to
go to the side open the leg and then
when you are collecting you turn the
torso so that by the time you reach the
zero position you do appear from here
you are going to go back this is the
most difficult part your free foot is in
the top position be careful with the
hill don't pull it outside put it inside
then when you are collecting to go to
the zero position you turn the torso so
that by the time you reach zero musician
you have peeled and then from here
you're going to go again to the side and
then when you collect you turn the torso
by the time you collect the food you
have finished the period okay so one
more time is going to be don't collect
people side collect people back collect
people side collect peel and I'm already
sound like
okay so we're going to use the metronome
again and remember the important thing
is that no matter what you do with your
standing leg be whatever your free leg
is always moving always moving you never
make stops in each position okay always
moving
truly this is the most important thing
so let's put the metronome again two
beats per bar and always and 58 good BM
[Music]
okay so we start in zero position
Elizabeth a climbs yeah will repeat the
whole sequence eight times
so get ready clicks together bend the
knees arms in tango grace
so we were always away okay now we put
the weight on the right
okay okay now we are going to put the
weight again on the left leg we're going
to work with my right leg not this time
after each position we're going to do
the people towards the standing leg yeah
so in this direction that will front and
side and back and side controlled okay
so like before with eight times
[Music]
okay
and now we will do the same to the other
side so we put the weight on the right
we work on the left and after the front
position with the knife when we return
with the people covers the standing leg
so in this direction not so it's what
you look like it's one then side then
back then side and then don't
okay so let's do it together eight times
[Music]
okay because this is difficult
meanwhile you do the exercise you will
have the tendency maybe to open the arms
or to raise the arms and this is going
to affect your balance he's going to
make it difficult so I recommend that
during the exercise you try to keep the
arms look yeah below the chest yeah
this would help a lot with your balance
now the second combination let's
remember it was simpler it was from zero
position with the footing pretty
position going forward knife then again
zero and then we have two inside we were
back total position okay and then see
you it was only ladies from 0 but 0 from
0 not bossy so then is also true you
spirits here after each position we do a
pivot so start front and then when we
collect we do a pivot let's start going
away from the standing leg and then we
will go back directly back and then when
we collect we will do another
and we will upfront we collect another
people we go back we collect another
female we were strapped okay
and then we will do it with the other
leg
okay so we do it eight times with each
leg again we use a little bit together
this one is a bit more difficult I find
it a bit more difficult because we don't
have side stick to study ourselves but
it's okay now it's to the other side put
the weight on the right and then go for
this one's not
[Music]
okay okay
now we will repeat with the right leg at
this time
after going front we're going to turn
welcome to the pivot towards the
standing wave in this direction which is
going to look like is front he would
back people stunt people back and then
from the game okay so let's be together
when the knees is important
come on grace push down and you do the
pivot and let's go one
[Music]
and now we will do the same the other
leg
so put your weight on the right left is
three and then when you go from time you
use the knife and then you collect
you're going to do the people in the
direction of the standing so to this
direction and then you will go back then
people tourists family from people
towards the standing leg godt people
tourists under the front I'm going to
take x okay so it's time like the other
men nice straight posture
[Music]
one two three four okay so that was it
for today thank you very much for
watching and for doing it with me
hopefully practice repeat each block if
you want several times challenge
yourself put faster tempos or slower and
let me know in the comments how these
exercises are going for you okay thank
you very much and see you the next one